so anyway I want to introduce you all to
a rich agar agar Allah who is standing
over here right now but you'll see him
in a moment RIT is actually just had the
good fortune of moving back to the East
Coast he is he was living on the west
coast for for a few years three years
for three years he was teaching at
Stanford a public policy and
sustainability class and he's now here
and he's on the faculty at Columbia
teaching I guess the same class and
maybe some other things and I suspect
he's very happy to be back at Columbia
because I learned that he has three
degrees from Columbia so he's got his
undergraduate degree a master's degree
and a PhD from Columbia so he's back in
the right place it seems like after
graduating after how him twenty-five
years that he spent there or whatever it
was after graduating he went on to do a
few different things some of which I
will mention and some of which I'm gonna
put off for a minute
but worked for the Federal Railroad
Administration he he worked for the city
of New York and and in all of these jobs
well not not the railroad administration
job but in some of these jobs they had
they had one important thing in common
which I'm saving to the end because I
feel like whenever Rick gets introduced
he probably gets introduced in the
context of Michael Bloomberg and I
didn't want that to be the first thing I
brought up and I I wanted to get rich
you stew it cuz I suspect that you know
the next month or so when when Michael
Bloomberg is no longer the mayor we
won't hear from anymore that'll be
that'll be the end of Michael Bloomberg
in the news so you're not going to get
that connection all the time so I
figured I would just sort of get you
used to that where the heck is Michael
Bloomberg becomes the norm right but but
in the context of Michael Bloomberg it
has worked for the city of New York as
the director of long-term planning and
sustainability and was one of the
instrumental brains behind PlaNYC
he works for C 40s the climate
leadership group what you're gonna hear
a little more about today as a special
adviser to the mayor who is the chair to
Mayor Bloomberg who is the chair of c40
and he works as the sort of the head of
the environmental track at Bloomberg
philanthropies so he has a lot of
different perspectives that all relate
to
urbanization and the environment and
particularly climate change which is
what this series we that you've all been
a part of for this semester is about
climate change and and regional
perspectives and tonight the regional
perspective is urbanisation now this is
the
last of the series for this semester so
thanks to all of you who have been here
for multiple events we will have another
series which we're calling the climate
in energy bookshelf next semester
there'll be four other great speakers
who all have interesting perspectives on
climate and energy not adaptation this
time but I hope you'll come back and
join us for all of those so RIT I'm
gonna leave it to you thanks thank you
for that uh under Bloomberg introduction
I'm not sure I'm gonna go home and
report to the boss that he's gonna fade
away I have no expectation that he will
and I think the world would be worse off
if he did so in any case thanks for the
invitation it's a great pleasure to be
here despite my light-blue affiliation
it's always nice to be here at a darker
shade of blue and and only a train ride
away from my once--and and once again
home what I thought I'd talk about
tonight and of course the title is I
think urbanization and resilience all
I'll try to do both mitigation and
resilience a little bit of justice and I
will also actually try to keep things at
a relatively high level so we can
reserve a fair bit of time for questions
because I expect your questions would be
more interesting than my prepared
remarks regardless so I'll try to do
that but what I what I thought I'd talk
about quickly is tell you a bit about
the c40 in part because as somebody
works for the c40 I have to give a
commercial for the c40 any time Isis
open my a mouth the second thing is to
tell you a little bit about why I think
cities are so important to this issue
you know a couple of years ago when when
c40 was really in its infancy I went was
Mayor Bloomberg and we stood outside the
béla Center in Copenhagen Copenhagen and
the mayor's were there kind of is a
little sideshow a little insurgency and
since then I think people really have
begun to appreciate that cities are the
heart of the matter when it comes to
climate change it's not a coincidence
and I think it's worth
thinking a little bit about why that is
and then the final thing I thought I'd
talk about is a couple of ways that at
least I have observed and think about
resilience and climate change adaptation
in an urban context because as much as
cities are a topic as much as cities
have a lot in common there are also
different problems in different cities
and we can learn a great deal I think
from the way different cities tackle
different challenges and we have to
always remember that there are different
characters as much as there are
similarities so we start out always
talking about c40 with the context that
the world's mega cities are in fact on
the forefront of climate change both on
the fight against climate change and on
the receiving end of climate change and
so whether it's traffic or flooding or
energy consumption and energy efficiency
or solid waste its cities where these
things take place its cities where these
problems are felt and it is important to
note that it's cities where we are
beginning to deal with it the best the
c40 cities climate leadership group is
an organization of Mayors 63 mayor's
from around the world representing the
largest of the world cities by and large
founded in 2005 by then Mayor of London
Ken Livingstone currently chaired by
Michael Bloomberg for another couple of
weeks we'll have an announcement next
week on the next chair and Ron really as
a self-governing membership organization
and this is important we are not an
advocacy group we are not trying to tell
the mayor's what they ought to be doing
or to convince them to do something
different than what they are currently
doing what we do is we help mayors of
the world's mega cities get their
climate change agendas accomplished
better faster and hopefully more
ambitiously by connecting them with
their peers and we do that because we
believe that the cities of the world
already have a great deal of collective
insight into how to make change happen
the c40 cities well this is a map of all
the c40 cities as I said we have 63
members of which 40 some-odd are true
mega cities the remainders are what we
call innovator cities smaller cities
that we know have great lessons to teach
the world's largest cities in the former
category we run the gamut from gigantic
places like Mexico City and Tokyo and
London to the innovator cities which
include places like Copenhagen and
Curitiba and Portland Oregon and we get
them together on a regular basis at
multiple levels within their
organizations and this is also critical
the mayors have good conversations with
mayors commissioners have good
conversations with commissioners program
managers need to have good conversations
with program managers all of the levels
of government are necessary for
different conversations you might think
that 63 cities alone is not that big
compared to the challenge of the world's
problem with climate change but in fact
these 63 mayor's in the c40 have either
influenced or direct election by 8% of
all humans more than 500 million people
live in a c40 City we contribute we
believe roughly 5% of global emissions
about 1.7 billion tons and this is
particularly stunning we account for 21%
of the world GDP think about what that
means one out of every five dollars of
value created by the human economy takes
place in one of our 63 metro areas it's
a very big deal to think about it
differently population wise we're like
the United States and Brazil in terms of
carbon emissions we're the same as the
entire country of Japan and in fact we
have an economy equivalent to the size
of China we also have tremendous power
to reduce carbon
worldwide in fact we estimate that with
the kinds of achievable things we know
are possible if the entire c40 city
really does entire c40 network really
does live up to what we believe the
promise could be in terms of climate
change mitigation we have more than 1
billion tons in annual emissions
reductions that are possible that's the
same as taking Canada and Mexico and
making them entirely carbon neutral or
taking all of the cars in the United
States off the road it's a big
possibility we have even better is the
fact that it isn't just theoretical what
we know is that cities are already
acting the world's mayor's have the
power and the willingness to act on
climate change this is for a couple of
important reasons around the world urban
dwellers and urban voters tend to be
more willing to embrace climate change
as a real issue to embrace the solutions
that are necessary to live more carbon
efficiently and have a level of comfort
with the kind of changes in society that
these innovations that a low-carbon life
requires and of course it's also in part
because of the fact that the greatest
risks from climate change they are
facing our world cities 90% of all urban
regions are in coastal areas the c40
cities are already dealing with the full
range of the impacts of climate change
from water supply challenges to the
other end of that same equation which is
flooding even more importantly the
world's mayors actually have
jurisdiction over the decisions that
affect climate change by and large if
you eliminate and of course it's a big
topic if you eliminate energy supply the
generation of electricity
and you take aside agriculture and
deforestation basically all of the other
direct policy levers that affect climate
wind up being to a large part delegated
to municipal government 87 percent of
the world's mayor's who are at least of
the c40 mayors have control over city
streets and parking 80% over outdoor
lighting I don't have to read to you all
of the statistics that are in front of
you but even things like building
regulation which is what directly
affects energy efficiency in most of the
world cities that's a municipal
responsibility an urban land use of
course in at least half the world cities
are urban responsibilities what we see
is that this is what allows mayor's to
lead because they have the political
support to do things and they have the
policies at their fingertips they don't
have to act through political bang shots
they don't have to ask lower levels of
government to do things they don't have
to create incentive plans they actually
can go ahead and do things and in fact
what we see already this is in fact
several years old we do a biennial
survey of c40 cities to find out what
actions they have taken what programs
they have accomplished this was data
gathered in 2010 released in early 2011
next February we will have our next c40
mayoral summit we will be releasing an
update to this not to this report which
will have a significantly higher set of
numbers I'm sure but we catalogued four
thousand seven hundred and thirty-four
discreet climate actions that took place
in the various c40 cities and
unsurprisingly if you think about the XY
axis of what's important and what mayors
have control have control over excuse me
what you see is the greatest level of
activity are in those areas where
mayor's have a great deal of control
because mayor's are willing to act here
we see a great deal on building
regulation my hunch is in fact that over
the next in the next survey we'll see
even more around City Planning
particularly around city streets just as
I early piece of information I've been
stunned to see how quickly bike sharing
has taken off around the world something
that only six years ago was kind of an
innovative idea out of Paris and one or
two other cities now 36 of the 63 c40
cities have an active bike sharing
system why is that well it has a number
of benefits for cities it's easy to
implement or actually in our third
generation of bike sharing concepts
around the world already that the New
York one that was implemented this
summer is really the third generation
think about what that means in policy
replication terms and what's even more
important is that in firstly every case
no mayor needed anybody else's approval
to do it that allows mayor's to act
quickly and so what c40 does is we're a
network we get our mayor's together we
get commissioners together we get our
program managers together in various
cities and we help them talk to each
other because cities don't compete with
each other they are willing to learn
from each other they have ideas that can
be replicated whether it's bike sharing
or bus rapid transit or benchmarking for
buildings these are ideas that if one
city adopts them it paves the way for
every other city to adopt them c40
itself as I said is not an advocacy
organization we merely exist to help our
cities figure out how to do their jobs
better we do that in three ways direct
peer-to-peer exchange through networks
formed around specific topics where we
try to get the person who is in charge
of a given project to get to know his or
her peers in other cities that are like
that city we do that electronically and
we do that through in-person meetings we
provide on the ground city support
technical assistance and small doses
meetings that we actually find to be
tremendously helpful in bringing people
together and increasingly we're starting
an exchange program so city officials
can do not just a visit but a couple of
weeks a month or
so working in a in a comparable office
abroad and we do research because of
course this has to be underpinned by the
kind of data that I showed you where
whether it's online speaking to the more
general public reports or what we now
have in fact our c40 exchange up there
which is a global intranet for city
officials who have jurisdiction over
climate change in a protected space
password accessible many of you who have
government experience know that there
are certain things that you are willing
to tell your peers but you cannot say to
the general public and that creates a
very powerful level of trust and
information exchange sorry and of course
data because not only do we have to
gather our own data we have to
facilitate the gathering of the data
that the cities themselves are
generating so that it can be accessible
and understandable in a single location
now that's what we do and that's why
cities are so important I thought I'd
spend the next few minutes before I turn
it over to questions talking about some
of the resilience challenges because I
know that's one of your overarching
themes for the for the semester and of
course particularly as somebody who's
now moved back to New York none of us in
this area can get over hurricane sandy
it is something that will remain I think
with us for quite a while although we
also know that times move on and the
political discussions move on and a big
question for all of us is going to be
how long the memory of that event can be
kept alive in a productive way but the
question I start out with here is
resilience in the world of climate
change policy is a bit of the late comer
in part because it was for a while kept
aside because so many people who thought
about this issue did not want the world
to focus on adaptation because it might
become a substitute for mitigation we've
seen it take over whether we wanted it
or not in many cities I think around the
world resilience is the more important
issue for most mayors because it more
directly
affects Public Safety and quality of
life particularly in the global south
how it relates to cities winds up being
very similar to mitigation we've see
similar levels of mayoral and municipal
control over the topics of climate
change resilience mayors and
municipalities have control over where
people live through zoning most mayor's
have responsibility to provide their
cities with clean fresh safe drinking
water which is of course a big challenge
in a world of changing climate as we saw
transit and streets are often within the
jurisdiction of city governments and
those are some of the systems that break
down first in extreme weather events
emergency responses in many cases
something that the city bears at least
primary responsibility for and of course
what we've seen in several events even
in this country is when the federal
government falls down on the job it's
often the city government that has to
pick up the slack and come to the rescue
and then of course neighborhood health
in many large cities around the world is
something that's delegated down to the
municipal level so just as in mitigation
the world's mayors are whether they like
it or not on the front lines of dealing
with mitigation and of course as I
already mentioned the direct impacts are
most acutely felt in our largest cities
most large cities are coastal and urban
dwellers are in fact more dependent on a
functioning shared infrastructure so
when the lights go out and the subway
goes down and the elevators stopped
working that's a bigger challenge in
Manhattan than it is in a rural area
there's no way around it it's an even
bigger challenge in Hong Kong and an
even more dangerous challenge in Rio the
challenge is that cities face when it
comes to resilience though do differ
around the world they don't necessarily
differ with income they don't
necessarily differ with the kind of
government but they do differ in the
same way that some cities have a bigger
challenge in terms of reducing carbon
emissions from transportation others
from buildings others from solid wastes
we see a variety of challenges rising to
the four
in different cities in some cases it's
either because of their geographical
location
or in some cases it's in fact because
problems were already solved by previous
generations for a variety of reasons and
that may well have had nothing to do
with climate change so we start out with
heat and drought and what's interesting
by my pointing out Melbourne and London
as two cities all I'll highlight when it
comes to dealing with heat and drought
is that these are not the necessarily
the cities that you'd point out as being
the hottest of course and they're also
coastal cities and you might say well
wouldn't a place like Melbourne have a
big challenge with sea level rise just
like New York does well in fact the city
of Melbourne has seen some of the most
dramatic changes in its summer heat
profile over the last decade and that
has called public attention and
political will to the issue of what
climate change will do to the summers in
Melbourne in fact back in 2009 right
before the Copenhagen summit in fact
they suffered one of the worst heat
waves in fact Melbourne had three days
of 115 degrees Fahrenheit think about
that in a city that actually is
accustomed to relatively mild weather
the transit system stopped working
because all the rails buckled they had
brown outs and then blackouts there were
massive health impacts around the city
and then they had a huge wave of brush
fires that halted the entire region's
economy the news focused on the brush
fires in fact we've forgotten that
already the city had begun to shut down
because its infrastructure was falling
apart under the weight of the heat what
a place like Melbourne is doing on heat
waves is a relatively straightforward
set of mitigations the nice thing about
some of these challenges is that they
aren't necessarily expensive they aren't
necessarily high-tech they aren't
necessarily big projects Melbourne is
planting trees it's pretty
straightforward it's pretty simple to do
it at scale
in a medium-sized city like Melbourne is
actually a logistical challenge and you
find that that is the bigger challenge
with some of these things which is not
how do you figure them out but how do
you get them done at the scale you need
similarly in London where another it is
an estuary city they have the risk of
sea level change being an issue for them
many of you may know that there is the
thames barrier that was put in place
more than 20 years ago because of
violent storms whether we want to
ascribe that to the early stages of
climate change or not I'm I'm not sure
nothing I've seen suggests it really has
to do with the secular rise in sea level
at that time it was much more an overall
risk mitigation challenge but as a
result sea level rise isn't really a big
issue for the city of London over the
next generation but heat is because even
more than Melbourne ISM sure most of you
have been to London at some point what's
missing in London air conditioning they
don't have air conditioning they're
simply not prepared for it because it
has never been an issue and yet when you
start having summers when you routinely
have days and weeks where the
temperatures are in the 90s you begin to
have the same challenges that the rest
of the air-conditioned world has they've
started to find that they have more
disruptions on the tube on hot days why
it's not that the rails are buckling
it's not that the system the signal
systems fall apart is that there are
people getting heatstroke on the subway
platforms that stop the trains while the
medical personnel can get there the good
news is some of these actually have
remarkably simple solutions simple
adaptations in 1k and you know the
obvious solution in London and the tube
is to air-conditioned the trains they're
going to do that over time the faster
when you put water on the platforms or
in drinking water because that will help
people not get heatstroke if they're
thirsty and they get a drink of water it
helps reduce the likelihood that they'll
faint what does that do it helps the
trains run on time right kind of a
thoughtful approach it's
not necessarily a high-tech solution it
doesn't prevent the summers from getting
hotter but it is a way that a thoughtful
municipal government can start to
mitigate to be more resilient to the
effects of climate change sea level rise
and floods inundation from the ocean of
course is something of course we we all
saw it only a year ago here in New York
Rotterdam is arguably the world's
marquee city in terms of dealing with
inundation and the sea rising and of
course their city sinking a generation
ago with the Delta Works Ho Chi Minh
City in Vietnam is actually highly
exposed to sea level rise being on the
edge of the Mekong Delta and being quite
built around a series of coastal areas
and inland waterways what we see in
these cities is of course the tension
between do you try to keep the water out
or do you expect that it's going to come
in here in New York being so close to
the city I'm sure many of you have been
paying more attention to this then you
might have a year ago but the big
question here is do you build a barrier
across the Narrows to keep the water out
of New York Harbor or you do you deal
with it in a different way
Rotterdam of course chose one in fact in
Ho Chi Minh City they've never had them
the funding to be able to keep the water
out entirely
they've whether they wanted to or not
they've found low-cost innovations to
develop systems where if the water comes
in it's not so damaging and of course
we'll see exactly how the policy plays
out in New York Mayor Bloomberg has
proposed something more like the Ho Chi
Minh example some others have still been
more adamant that we need the flood
level barriers but what I would argue
about sea level rise and inundation is
that like with London and the drinking
water on the subway platform right there
are also a host of much smaller much
faster innovations that one can bring to
bear right we did see this in the
Rockaways where despite the fact that
Arverne by the sea in the Rockaways and
queens was built recently Mayor
Bloomberg was criticized for allow
yet to be built at the same time that he
was talking about the threat that
climate change had and yet that
community right there facing the brunt
of Hurricane sandy actually had very
little damage because it was built with
the understanding that floods were
inevitable in that area the dunes were
shaped to deflect the power of the waves
the basements were designed to be
flooded the electrical equipment was not
below the flood line and therefore those
buildings were inhabitable throughout
the storm in fact even though they were
in an evacuation zone and people went
back home very quickly
the neighboring neighborhoods that were
built 50 years ago and had none of those
precautions taken were decimated right
and so in fact I would argue that the
key thing here is simply thinking
frankly about what you're going to face
and building to accommodate it
it requires the power of government
because almost nobody will do that on
their own but this is where zoning and
building codes and design standards
allow mayors to make a very big
difference in what takes place and in
the dangers that their communities face
over time
another type of challenge that cities
around the world are facing and we see
this in fact mostly in the developing
world but not entirely in the developing
world is the threat of violent storms
and extreme precipitation of course you
know we confuse the two when we often
use the word flooding to describe both
but they're very different events what
we had in Hurricane sandy was in
inundation from the ocean what we had a
year before that was Hurricane Irene was
violent precipitation didn't hit the
city as much as it did upstate New York
but what we see in places like Rio and
Bangkok is the tendency for landslides
and and neighborhoods and buildings to
collapse under the weight of the water
creating massive disruption and of
course death in Rio the mayor of Rio has
become a bit in the spotlight not just
because of the World Cup not just
because of the Olympics coming to his
City but IBM talks about
how much work they've been able to do
for him so if you listen to any smart
city's pitch in the first ten minutes
you will hear about Rio and this is a
really interesting thing that's happened
right because you have all these favelas
on the hillside in Rio obviously not
really built any good building standards
informal arguably illegal settlements
when the rain comes
there are mudslides people always die
Rio like San Francisco is a city with
microclimate so you can have different
weather going on in different parts of
the city at a given point and what IBM
was able to do was help bring predictive
capability at a pinpoint level so they
could figure out well all right here's
the type of here's the here's the
extremity of rainfall that is likely to
trigger a rain a landslide in this
neighborhood can we predict an hour in
advance before that happens because then
we can get a warning out and it is
remarkable it's a great application of
technology to give the city of Rio the
ability to do that what's often
forgotten though is that the information
is only half the battle
right and what I would call your
attention to when we think about what
Rio has done is the fact that down at
the community level they've managed to
create the protocols create trust in
government and create a deep network of
people in neighborhoods most of whom are
volunteers who have the training who are
set up that when the alarm sounds or
when they get the text message they go
into action and everybody knows where
the evacuation center is everybody knows
which door which buildings they're
supposed to go yell at and who in their
neighborhood might be missing and didn't
evacuate right and so I think this is an
important thing to think about when you
think about adaptation regimes or
resilience regimes some of it's the high
tech some of it's the basic day-to-day
blocking and tackling of management how
do you organize communities and
hopefully thus far
knock on wood Rio in the three years
since this was implemented has not
actually had a death from landslides
which previously was an
occurence hopefully the system lasts
longer but thus far it's proven itself
um and then of course disease which i
think many of you are probably aware of
this is in fact Nairobi is not yet a c40
city so I'm a bit talking out of school
hopefully we don't have too many c40
cities that are dealing with this
challenge as acutely as Nairobi is but
many of you may well know that Nairobi
has traditionally not been susceptible
to malaria but as the climate has
changed the mosquito that that carries
malaria has now come to thrive in
Nairobi I think this is an area that we
haven't seen that much of but we will
see far more of in fact the new york
city green codes building taskforce that
gave a number of recommendations to city
government a couple of years ago in fact
had put in place a recommendation for
window screens because we are expecting
in new york over the next 20 or 30 years
to have more of these insect borne
diseases that are generally associated
with tropical countries so again if you
think about something as simple as a
window screen being a climate change
adaptation and one that is susceptible
to municipal enforcement and enhancement
that is the way i would argue we need to
be thinking about cities and climate
change adaptation so to bring this to a
close and and help turn this over to
your questions i think the first thing
that i draw from this that i draw from
what i've seen at least around the world
is this distinction between resilience
and climate change adaptation i think
it's actually very good for us all that
we're now focused more on resilience
than on adaptation adaptation narrows
the focus to those things that will
change over the next 20 or 30 years what
resilience has helped us do and i think
has been particularly healthy in new
york unfortunately at the terrible cost
of hurricane sandy is focus us on the
breadth of threats many of which are
simply greater enhancements to threats
that we've been living with but didn't
fully appreciate for a generation or
more right hurricane sandy could well
have happened
thirty years ago before there was
appreciable rise in sea levels or
appreciable temperature change in the
ocean it could well have happened New
York is in the path of hurricanes on
occasion it simply didn't it's more
likely to over time but everything that
happened we were already susceptible to
and so being resilient more broadly like
I know from personal experience when you
talk about climate change adaptation you
wind up really only having the ability
to address a subset of what the broader
urban resilience agenda can and should
do infrastructure not the only solution
I think we see that in the contrast
between a place like Rotterdam in Ho Chi
Minh City unfortunately one of the risks
is that engineering firms and others are
more likely to make money out of the
infrastructure project since those those
will often have a more prominent place
in the discourse just because there are
more people interested in that being the
solution but as good policy makers we
always have to be skeptical about the
high dollar solution as opposed to the
low dollar solution they may both have
their place IT also smart cities are a
great thing but I'd argue smart cities
alone are like the calculator the
computer that sits under the desk if you
don't use it for something productive it
adds no value and in the same way I
think what Rio provides as an example or
IT paired with good management allows
you to be highly resilient and that is
really my overall belief which is that
good
urban managers which is good mayor's are
ultimately I think the reason that
cities are at the forefront people who
are not focused on ideological battles
people who have services to deliver
people who have things that if they
don't get to their citizens they will
notice I will point out we had a real
experiment here in the United States the
federal government shut down for a
couple of weeks how many of you were
actually inconvenienced okay some but
let me point out that looks like about
20% three weeks no federal government
20% if the trash didn't get picked up
how many of you would notice within a
couple of days if the bus didn't come
these are things that you rely on you
would call City Hall in a heartbeat to
complain about and what that does is it
focuses mayor's on being good managers
not on being policymakers not on being
ideologues they have services deliver to
deliver and I think what makes mayor's
at the forefront of climate change
issues both mitigation and adaptation
what makes them effective is the fact
that the policies that are designed in
city halls are there to be implemented
and tested in the real world as opposed
to fought over and legislators that's
why I think the c40 cities will help
make a difference thank you
and more advertising okay so we're gonna
be running these mics around for people
who have questions so raise your hand
and either a me or I will deliver a mic
to you and and I don't normally do this
but I want to actually ask the first
question if you don't mind back in the
beginning of your description of c40 in
the role of cities you had a stat that
was cities cities emit five percent of
greenhouse gases that strikes me is very
low can you a see 40 cities the see 46
so are 63 cities only 5% yeah
and it is a remarkable thing but what it
what it attests to is the fact that all
else being equal if you if you accept a
similar standard of living an urban
setting is far more efficient than a
sprawling suburban or rural setting
right and so even though in a place like
China where the where the cities on a
per capita basis emit far more carbon
than the rural areas that's about wealth
and consumption but when you get up to a
point where the standard of living in a
country say you know Mexico like a
mid-level developed country the standard
of living between the cities and the
rural areas is nowhere near as
pronounced you actually begin to see
that curve changed of course it's highly
acute in a place like New York thank you
okay now everybody else can ask
questions thank you very much that's
very very interesting could you tell us
a little bit about how c40 is funded how
do you get the resources necessary to do
the research to call the meetings and to
to engage the the networks it's it's
just it's we're in that way we're an NGO
we have philanthropic donors Bloomberg
philanthropies funds children's
investment fund foundation in Britain we
hope to have a new funder from the
European continent that we can announce
in a month or so but it's its
foundations mainly
thanks for your talk was wondering in
terms of mitigation can cities undertake
measures directed more toward mitigation
and I'm thinking in particular or as an
example building energy efficiency
ESCO at the ESCO model I'm thinking
electric recharging stations to promote
use of electric vehicles
thanks well I think you know I I didn't
stress the mitigation in part because in
part because of the theme but I in fact
thus far most of the world's city's
actions have been on mitigation so the
the clear answer to your question is yes
and as I said I think it winds up
correlating primarily to what mayors
have powers over so we've seen a massive
global transformation in the way that
the public realm is being managed
whether it's in Bogota or Copenhagen
which was really at the world's leader
in this now New York I I like to think
has been a leader in this but since
mayors have control over city streets
the creation of public plazas of bike
lanes and things like that are something
that once a mayor believes it's
necessary once the City Council is on
board that it's necessary it can be done
relatively quickly in cities where you
have control over the building codes we
are seeing aggressive City action we've
seen it Tokyo now has a cap-and-trade
system in place for its large buildings
that every build every skyscraper in
Tokyo has a legally mandated target for
total energy consumption reductions and
they can trade they can sell credits if
they exceed their target they can they
can buy credits if they fall short but
it's ensured that the overall
consumption of all of the massive number
of skyscrapers in Tokyo is steadily
going down by act of the Tokyo
Metropolitan Government in New York we
put in place a mandatory benchmarking
and retro
missioning package called the greener
greater buildings plan which now in fact
we were I think the second city in the
United States to mandate benchmarking
and disclosure in large buildings I
think now eleven cities around the
country have adopted this and primarily
large cities because its most relevant
for cities with with lots of large
buildings but Boston adopted at
Chicago's adopted at Philadelphia so I
think you do see the cities taking the
lead on on many of these things my
question had to do a bit more with
terminology I'm over I'm over here you
mentioned that that it's a that we're
shifting away from adaptation and
towards resilience and this is just a
basic question my understanding was that
they're sort of the same you know if
you're gonna adapt you're gonna be as
more resilient so just curious if you
could clarify its you're you're right
people use them interchangeably I
actually see in nuance that I think is
important and that's that's why I make
this distinction I think if if you do an
analysis on okay how do I adapt to a
change in climate what you say is all
right here's my climate today the
climates gonna get two degrees hotter
ain't making that up right fine what do
I have to do to deal with things being
two degrees hotter right it's a very
narrow definition right for one the
second is adaptation at least had come
to me and essentially hardening how do
we keep out the climate so rather than
providing water on the platform it's how
do we air-conditioned the tube and I
think it is far better to think about
resilience in two ways one is resilience
is overall resilience whether it's about
climate change or not it's about climate
risks and how are we resilient to the
broad package of risks that as I said
maybe we've faced for generations maybe
they don't have to do with a two degrees
change in the weather or in the climate
but that helps us both broaden the scope
of what we're doing in terms of making
our cities better and more livable it
also frankly helps deep politicize
the issue because if if I don't believe
that climate change is real I'm not
gonna be interested in helping you with
climate change adaptation but if you're
gonna tell me that you know I don't have
to believe that we're gonna have more
hurricanes you can just tell me that
we've had hurricanes and we're gonna do
something about making our city more
resilient to those hurricanes I think
you you helped create a broader base of
support you also I think wind up with a
far more nuanced way of thinking about
climate events and what a city has to do
to deal with them alright there's the
argument for a seawall for example which
I've always considered to be somewhat
unnecessary so I've always been a
skeptic of the seawall solution for New
York City right - my mind is akin to
saying well ok we have a blizzard and we
should build a dome over the city to
keep the snow off the street right well
we don't do that because it would be
potentially physically feasible but
insanely expensive and create all sorts
of secondary problems right what we do
is we figure out well ok if you have a
massive snow storm you're going to shut
down the city for a day how do you make
sure number one that nobody dies right
how do you get the emergency services
how do you protect the subway keep it
running things like that right and
number two how do you get back to
business as quickly as possible
that's resilience resilience is about
bouncing back it's not about keeping the
weather at bay right and so I think
that's a very different approach
hi thanks so much for your presentation
so I run our project here at Yale where
we rank countries based on their
environmental performance and you made a
comment earlier that you said cities
don't compete with each other and so I
was curious to see if you had any more
comments around that because what we've
seen in our project is that countries do
compete with each other so once we
develop this ranking and we release it
on a biannual basis countries pay
attention to the ranking and they say oh
I'm doing worse in Japan or Korea is
doing better than me and so we see that
that actually galvanizes a race to the
top and and encourages countries to
compete against each other so it's
morning if you thought about similar
types of frameworks or metrics for your
c40 cities that might actually encourage
them not to only share best practices
but actually to compete with each other
to raise the bar even higher
well we so I'll tell you my own personal
perspective on that is I don't believe
that rankings are ultimately all that
helpful and it's because and and
hopefully yours is far more thoughtful
than the average Bears but at least in
my experience most rankings are pretty
coarse and not helpful so the example
that I usually give is New York is a
highly dense transit oriented city and
if you have a ranking on how good the
transportation is from an environmental
point of view
Los Angeles is uncompetitive right if
I'm the mayor of Los Angeles it is not
helpful to be told you rank below New
York and transportation right it doesn't
encourage anything it's like telling
somebody who's 5 feet tall that they're
just not that good at basketball right
it doesn't make you work harder at
basketball right in fact what's helpful
is when you take it to the next level
and you figure out all right among
cities that have a certain density
profile right what are the things that
can be done and what cities are doing
which right
that to my mind is helpful because then
you're not only telling somebody oh you
know you're at the bottom but you're
also showing them the path to climb to
the top right
that's what c40 actually focuses its its
efforts on we have started an awards
program we did the
series of awards last September as a
partnership with Siemens in ten
categories where we look at the the most
and and we define the most inspiring so
we are actually quite broad in how we
judge these but the most inspiring
climate initiatives in given topics
waste energy etc um part of our criteria
there is not just are you at the top of
your game because it's not that helpful
to have Copenhagen in San Francisco and
a handful of other cities get every
prize every year right what's helpful is
to say compared to where you were two
years ago how much progress have you
made so that's in the future what c40 is
going to be looking to celebrate and
award more so you're totally right it's
not that they don't have a competitive
sense it's not that cities are obviously
New York and London and Singapore and
Hong Kong these are cities that compete
with each other right for businesses
residents etc what's interesting is it's
not a zero-sum game right and that's I
think one of the things that changes the
discussion we see this week in Warsaw
that for some reason the world's
nation-states still can't get over
resentment and oh you know I don't want
to help myself because you're not
helping yourself so you know let the
planet burn up right
for some reason mayor's don't do that
right so New York and London arguably
two cities locked in the highest level
of competition because they share all
the same industries and whatever you
know and yet we have municipal
governments where we know all our
counterparts because we have a lot to
learn from each other and we both like
each other city right and so we're not
competitive in that sense it's not a
zero-sum game there's a sense of you
know if London can do this I could do
this but London will help me do this and
celebrate it when I do all right so I
think it's a different kind of
competition I hope that's helpful I
don't mean to challenge your ranking
system I'll look into your rankings I'm
sure it's quite thoughtful yes sir
to the extent that the city is either
under the rubric of climate change
adaptation or resilience are engaging in
activities that themselves have carbon
footprints and perhaps substantial ones
to what extent are these cities that are
obviously very cognizant of climate
change as a as a reality in as a as a
threat to what extent are they
attempting to perform those resilience
or adaptation measures in a way that
will be minimally carbon intensive it's
an interesting question I'm I'm not sure
it's one that's actually come up if I'm
understanding you correctly so if your
question is all right so you've got a
city like New York which takes takes
carbon emissions quite seriously has
done a lot on mitigation when it
developed and of course I was no longer
at New York City Hall by the time the
Sandy hit so I didn't play a part really
in the post sandy work but you know did
they take the various resilience
measures that are proposed in the
stronger more resilient New York report
did they take the carbon footprint of
each of those initiatives into account I
think that's your question right I
actually don't know I'd be a little
surprised if they did and I think there
is a how shall I say this there is a a
missing the forest for the trees
sometimes when we are focused on carbon
counting and we we do it too much and
I'd argue that you know yeah of course
you want to do the community footprint
you want to make sure that the trend is
going in the right direction am I going
to figure out which flight to take
because one airline has a more efficient
plane probably not right because even
less the management time it takes to do
that probably eats into itself for some
of the bigger things and I think the
bigger challenge in fact for City is one
of the cutting edge areas I believe of
research for some
you are researchers here is the overall
urban project and the embedded energy in
urban infrastructure and how that
complicates our analysis of carbon
efficiency because that's an area that
you know I know at least a couple of you
are working on overall urban metabolism
as a concept I'm not sure we've fully
gotten that right so that if we think
about the argument that I've made a
thousand times oh well the subway is far
more efficient than driving well okay
but it is true that a road is less
concrete intensive than a subway tube
right and whether over the life of a
hundred years of usage and a hundred
years of gasoline being burned I'm sure
that cancels it out so it's probably a
minor portion I don't think we know I
think that's the same question you're
asking so if you believe that a city is
worth protecting and you believe that a
city itself is environmentally a good
thing as I believe because as I said on
average a city is a far more efficient
way to live
then you should believe that it's worth
protecting that city and you must assume
that building even if you do go so far
as to build a seawall that the
incremental embedded carbon there is
more than canceled out by the savings
from protecting that city and not having
people sprawl out into the into the
countryside it's an assertion I don't
think the research is there so frankly I
think it would have been very difficult
for my colleagues at city halls for
example to put that into the post-sandy
work so I my short answer after a long
answer is no but it's not to say I don't
think it's it's necessarily valuable but
it's a tricky question okay I think we
have time for one more question probably
hi I'm wondering if you could talk about
the so there's been an emergence of lots
of different city networks and
initiatives over the past several years
and we had a conference here a couple of
weeks ago looking at the UN urban new
sustainability Development Goals and now
there's a there's gonna be an urban goal
and so I just I was wondering if you
could talk a little bit about how you
see all of these different initiatives
coming together and in what ways they're
complementary or conflicting and sort of
what you see going forward as as the
role of these sort of large urban
networks in addition to sort of maybe
from a conceptual standpoint how these
networks can contribute to learning
across cities or competition but then
from a very concrete practical
standpoint how we're gonna actually keep
on making things happen um in cities um
it's a good question and I think one of
the one of the things that I often think
about is well are we doing so much that
we're actually keeping people from doing
their day jobs right because you could
spend all your life going to conferences
and networks and things like that and
never get anything done and that would
be ultimately quite counterproductive
um and I think the the thing that helps
protect that is the fact that at least
good city governments have a very clear
need to deliver and so at least in my
experience most at least at c40 I
certainly have seen people turn down
free plane tickets and not go to events
because they'd say you know what
actually I don't think I'll get that
much out of attending this event right
in some cases they don't believe in what
we're doing in some cases they're far
more nuanced customers they actually
really find c40 valuable but they just
have something more important to do
instead of this one thing so I think by
and large over time it will settle down
urban is hot right now I mean there's no
question right everybody's focused on
cities if it were a stock I would
probably short it I think you know at
some point it will have to subside just
because it's so much the focus right now
in fact the way I think the bubble of
urban stuff will burst is the
realization that
if 75% of the world's people live in
cities at some point you stop talking
about urban you may talk about rural on
occasion but every conversation is urban
at that point and so one of the
challenges I think that a lot of these
networks and goals and everything has is
distinguishing what is it we're really
talking about right so in the World Bank
or the or un-habitat or the Census
Bureau talks about urbanized places
we're still talking about places of
5,000 people in a place that you and I
would look at and say that's not a city
all right that's a town it's not rural
but it's not a big city and so there is
something to be done in terms of
distinguishing between how is a mega
city different from a medium-sized city
different from what's really a large
town versus a rural area the things that
cut across the first three increasingly
those are just human problems they're
not urban problems anymore because we
all live in those places right and then
the areas to really focus on or what
distinguishes those other things I think
that's going to be part of the challenge
to solvent mature what you're talking
about potentially a fruitful area of
research I'm not sure I've really
answered your question but it's a hard
one to answer and and by the way then
one other question and one other answer
I'll make is well of course our network
is the most worthwhile
of course right thank you very much and
really thank you for coming thank you
for having me